the easiest way to describe it is why
they started studying it to begin with
okay and that was back almost 20 years
ago
oh dang they they realized that when
they gave ketamine
to patients getting operations they
required less narcotic pain medicine
um during the operation in the hospital
and after the hospital stay
uh than than other patients they said
why is this just doesn't
you know why are they having less pain
they had no explanation
so they they looked at it and what they
discovered was that what it does
is it changes your perception of pain
so you can see something that you've
experienced
as less painful hence
you don't need as much medication to
cover your pain i see so you're not
feeling as much pain because you're
not seeing it you're not seeing the seed
of whatever it was as as
painful so therefore like the growth of
the pain isn't as severe
at at that time uh the way the best way
i like to describe it to people is
yeah i have two daughters and and
say we go get flu shots and one daughter
gets a flu shot and she's like ow
and my other daughter she gets a flu
shot and she's like and
her response is much more okay we know
that the
the shot is the same
but the response is different so one is
perceiving something
with more distress than the other and
the way ketamine
works is it helps
your pain sort of shift from that
that more visceral response to a more
that hurt but i'm okay response okay
it's a pers it like it's like changing
the lens on how you see pain
so that you can see things and you can
kind of look at them from a distance and
sort of
go around things that have happened to
you and you can kind of connect to
yourself
from those places and it's a it's
it's it's not spiritual but it's not far
from it
right do you think it gives you like a
look at yourself like you kind of
see yourself whereas a lot of us have a
tough time seeing ourselves because
we're in ourselves you know
exactly yes 100 because it's like
if you're on the playing field you can't
really see
what's going on and it sort of puts you
up in the stands
of your life that's interesting and you
have a lot of places in your past
or a lot of patients that have come to
me is you know you're living your life
and life's hard and people get hurt
and depending on where they are in their
life they sort of package that up
and they put it away because they don't
want to feel that anymore
but it doesn't really go away and so
those those let's call them firewalls
um they're no-go places in your brain
but they're still sort of resonating
through your existence
so they're shaping typically your
relationships
and your career what's happening during
the experience when somebody gets the
ketamine what's happening
so the way the way i do it is
i i put a iv in them so i can like turn
it up and turn it down so you can slow
down if they start getting overwhelmed
okay because sometimes people you and
you can just see it you know
uh they're like because it's like
they're lot's coming at them
and and i'm sitting there and you
they tend to start having like their
blood pressure and their heart rate go
up because they're getting like they're
seeing stuff and
okay so you want to kind of try to
minimize that you want to make it
constructive yet um uh
sufficient to like have the experience
it can't be so low that you're like i
didn't feel anything
right but you don't want to like you
know
ruin them i mean not ruin them but you
don't want to make it so overwhelming
it's no longer
useful right i see what you're saying
yes so you want to kind of have a
find a balance and um yeah that's what
the one i did the place that i went they
they they did it and then they kind of
just it was a low dose until they kind
of
got to you to a level where they could
where it seemed like it was manageable
and effective i guess to communicate
with the therapist yeah because
what i do is you know the way the
research was done is you do six
six infusions and i like to have them
come in and i don't usually
have somebody start ketamine right away
i usually want to talk to them because i
want to know like
their life narrative to some degree and
then you kind of get an idea where
where the boundaries are like you can
tell like
i go through this thing where i'm like
okay how was um you know where'd you
live where'd you move
how was that place how was this place uh
how was first grade
how was second grade and you keep going
through it and
things start popping up pretty fast and
people don't realize what's in their
head and then they're like
oh yeah i forgot about that and
but you can kind of tell this is not in
ketamine this is just sort of getting to
know them
because you got to know what what are
you going to do with the ketamine
experience so i want to have like a road
map
right and and then as we do this the
first couple of sessions you want to get
there
they're sort of like get everything
chugging you just want to get them into
a better state of well-being so that
their capacity
to examine some of these long-standing
things
is available to them okay you don't want
them to
not be able to to sort of explore this
um you want them to be in fight good
enough fighting shape
that they're like i can do this um and
we go through it and i've had people who
couldn't remember entire years of their
lives
these are smart very successful people
who who have been it's like something's
been wrong their whole life
and and you start going through it with
them
and it keeps going back further and
further and further and it's sort of
like the
the beginning of the flick of the wrist
on that little
thread of pain and and a lot of times
these little firewalls conceal it
and then they have their ahas and they
remember more and more and more and i'm
not
telling them what to remember i'm just
listening
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you